ouais il y a une lumière la lumière du soleil sur la
réalisation juste un peu regarde là hein d'
accord
je ne peux pas récupérer Roger Roger Roger
la fabuleuse tante vida c'est moins cher
j'espère que tu l'aimes il y a un peu d'
embouteillage mais il n'y a aucune idée de ce que le
calendrier pour le téléphone je ne fais que  pour obtenir
une mise à jour sur les pièges, nous n'avons pas
encore de visuel de piste
ou nous n'en savions rien maintenant,
laissez-moi devenir plus énergique, mais si vous le
faites, la fusée sonne bien pour le vainqueur
, devons-nous vérifier pour venir juste  sur une
gauche si ce
rapport 135 Roger final et donc Victor sans
John sentait qu'il y avait venir ici donnez-nous une
chaîne le savoir vers le bas Victor télex refaire
voir une écologie vivant le coma terminal
monter peut-être que vous pourriez faire comme si vous
aviez un plan de vol
donc le plus grand  la grande grande grande roue
change ou comparée à la fausseté dans laquelle
nous sommes aujourd'hui d'
accord d'accord d'autres vers le bas
je ne sais pas peut-être cette rangée de belles maisons neuves
que j'ai descendues via la glace à la boulangerie
maison un peu de
mais  s'il s'en va avec th  ose petites
maisons sur les collines et vous n'aimez pas
ça hé pas de maisons mais nous les
contournons ouais non pas de coût de la vie
au-delà de
Missy jusqu'au
Hazzard ici d'
accord d'accord
et le Khalid zeerak l'hôtel est définitif
Viktor dit à Roger quand  3 4 0 à 21
rafales 28 Civic a noté les
risques de balles ici, nous allons y aller aussi,
puis nous venons de couper le droit
maintenant ouais
Oh laissez l'avion atterrir d'
accord vous mais pas ça maintenant ils l'ont emmené là-
bas  est bon avec un coup de feu
ah il n'y a rien maintenant ouais tu l'as
ouais j'ai compris
ce que je regarde ici ce sera de brèves
restrictions parfait d'accord
Khalid zeerak vos hôtels vers le bas une
clarté ce sont le
succès extraterrestre de l'hôtel Richter Roger sur votre recherche
Je ne la fais pas tomber celle-ci
un peu plus loin sur la glace
s'il vous plaît le reste de la liste
nous allons à vous la partie animée de la ville d'
accord laissez-moi demander à l'arc je ne pense pas
si je portais un peu couvert  mais d'accord je
vous dis que je ne vois pas les gens dehors mais le
l  les adies sont très changeants
feront ce village un ce soir c'est
mieux d'accord
c'est vraiment moche Merci telexfree
Roger est allé trois trois zéro à 96
et tu veux être séparé comme ça
Roger le lien à nouveau pour l'offre
Oh
peut-être un coup du hub de  un avion tu
sais d'accord L'aéroport montre l'immensité d'
eux
PDD dessus ouais mignon mais ouais on va
emballer dc-3 bien déchirure par larme dc-3 ce
livre quand tu fais là-bas à 350 a presse
le rouge ouais la pluie  bon ouais
ok garçon je t'ai fait : root' idée
tablier herculéen sur ok ouvert jusqu'à
demain reprendre sur un navigateur haut bleu
c'est
la pathologie que tu as une solution vecteur
V - 1 tablier 1
j'ai dit bien oui mais le cookie de la reine Jocaste a
classé la partie sur  tu marches
ici
le terrain là merci